fast 900 versteckte galaxien entdeckt
inwieweit das die wissenschaft
vorantreibt und was das ganze mit dem
großen attraktor dem sternen verschlingt
zu tun hat darum geht es heute bei pixum
science fiction
sie waren hinter unserer galaxie der
milchstraße verborgen im toten winkel
waren sie fast nicht aufzuspüren
fast forscher der university of western
australia in crawley haben ganz in
unserer nähe in einer entfernung von nur
250 millionen lichtjahren 883 galaxien
gefunden und jede dieser galaxien
enthält rund 100 milliarden sterne
dieser teil des universums war den
forschern bisher unbekannt obwohl er so
nah war
zitat diese 109 hinter der milchstraße
versteckten galaxien umfassen daher eine
menge masse von der wir bisher nichts
wussten so rené kram korte weg von der
university kapstadt
die galaxien befinden sich in der sonne
freut uns warum aber konnten die
galaxien noch nicht schon viel früher
entdeckt werden
unser sonnensystem ist ein teil der
milchstraße wie wir unseren galaxien
nennen und liegt am äußeren rand der
milchstraße eigentlich eine ganz gute
position um das all zu beobachten
trotzdem erreichen unserer teleskope
nicht genügend informationen aus dem all
um uns details über gewisse bereiche zu
geben zum beispiel über die die hinter
der milchstraße liegen zu viele
störfaktoren durch unsere eigene galaxie
mit dem parks radioteleskop stationiert
in australien konnten die forscher
jedoch eine spur bis zu den 883 galaxien
verfolgt zitat die 21 zentimeter linie
des wasserstoffs ermöglicht das
aufspüren von galaxien selbst durch
dickste stellare störsignale im
vordergrund hindurch die sonst
dahinterstehende galaxien im optischen
und im infrarotbereich maskieren
berichteten die experten die an 20
zentimeter beziehen sich auf die
wellenlänge die wasserstoff im vakuum
aussendet sie wird auch h1 liegen an sie
spielt in der radioteleskope
die eine große rolle da sie sich ihm
also gut ausbreiten kann und nicht von
unserer milchstraße verdeckt wird
im fachmagazin astronomical journal
erklärten die forscher auch inwieweit
die wissenschaft von dem fund profitiert
mit diesen galaxien werden wir zum
beispiel auch mehr über den großen
sternen verschlinge den großen attraktor
erfahren der große attraktor ist eines
der größten rätsel wenn es um die
bewegungen im universum geht es handelt
sich hierbei um ein filament so
bezeichnet man galaxienhaufen die farben
förmig miteinander verbunden sind seit
1970 ern weiß man von ihm eigentlich
dehnt sich das universum seit dem
urknall und auf völlig aus trotzdem
ziehen sich die galaxien und
galaxienhaufen gegenseitig an forschungs
ergebnisse besagen dass unsere
milchstraße auf diesen großen attraktor
zusteuert dessen anziehungskraft ist
nämlich so hoch dass ganze galaxien von
ihm angezogen werden er besteht aus dem
norma hydra und centaurus haufen und
darauf bewegt sich unsere milchstraße zu
ja in der tat und zwar mit 2 millionen
kilometern pro stunde es wird trotzdem
noch ewig dauern aber der große
attraktor der besteht aus mehreren
zehntausend galaxien hat also eine sehr
große menge an masse und beeinflusst
somit andere massen maßgeblich da der
einfluss so groß ist schätzen die
wissenschaftler die masse auf zehn
milliarden sonnenmassen
erinnert euch noch an ein
vorangegangenes zitat diese hunderten
neuen hinter der milchstraße versteckten
galaxien umfassen daher eine menge masse
von der wir bisher nichts wussten
diese neu entdeckte masse könnte uns
also weitere hinweise zu dem mysteriösen
attraktor bieten neben der möglichen
erkenntnis darüber muss natürlich jetzt
auch der atlas des universums auf den
neuesten stand gebracht werden
die astronomen bereits herausgefunden
haben befindet sich unsere milchstraße
also unsere galaxie am rand eines
galaxien superhaufen deren durchmesser
von 520 millionen lichtjahren hat wobei
das ist im weltall nicht besonders groß
das hat einen durchmesser so glauben
experten von rund 78 milliarden
lichtjahren mindestens allerdings was
eigentlich niemand wie groß genau das
weltall
ist ob es gekrümmt eine scheibe kugel
eine zu eat unendlich und so weiter ist
in diesen galaxien superhaufen sind aber
dennoch mehr als 100.000 galaxien diesen
superhaufen haben die forscher vanek er
getauft das ist hawaiianisch und
bedeutet unermesslicher himmel
hawaiianisch deshalb weil der bereich an
der universität hawaii erstmals kartiert
wurde um herauszufinden wo genau sich
die milchstraße in dieser galaxien
ansammlung befindet haben die
wissenschaftler die bewegungen von
anderen galaxien beobachtet so kamen sie
auf die wechselseitigen gravitative
einflüsse also die anziehungskräfte der
galaxien untereinander
die mussten sie aus der ausdehnung des
universums herausrechnen denn bereits
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war
für die wissenschaft klar
seit dem urknall dehnt sich das weltall
aus wasser 12 entdeckte der
amerikanische astronom bestes leifer
dass die spektrallinien des lichts weit
entfernter galaxien in den roten bereich
des spektrums verschoben sind ein effekt
der durch die ausdehnung der raumzeit
seit dem urknall hervorgerufen wird
kurz darauf bemerkte edwin hubble dass
das licht von galaxien eine größere
rotverschiebung hatte wenn sie in
größerer entfernung zu uns stehen im
jahr 1927 zog der belgische priester und
kosmologe georges lemaitre
eine kühne schlussfolgerung aus diesen
beobachtungen die ausdehnung des
universums musste vor endlicher zeit in
einem einzigen punkt begonnen haben
dieses ereignis ist uns allen als der
urknall der bigbank bekannt ja vergesst
nicht den daumen hoch zu machen für
dieses video wenn es euch gefallen hat
und erst vor kurzem wurden die
gravitationswellen entdeckt jetzt neue
galaxien
wir dringen immer tiefer in die welt der
elementarteilchen vor die teilchenphysik
die astrophysik überhaupt die ganze
wissenschaft macht immer neue
entdeckungen die supraleitung wird
inzwischen in der praxis angewendet
quantencomputer und verschlüsselung sind
inzwischen praxis was meint ihr stehen
wir vor dem großen sprung werden wir in
einer dramatisch veränderten zukunft
leben diskutiert es in den kommentaren
die besten videos von pixum gibt es
übrigens in der best of play list link
ist in der beschreibung und hier oben
unter dem i unbedingt ansehen und nicht
vergessen zu abonnieren
auf youtube ist das ja immer kostenlos
einfach auf den abo button klicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran